[Music]
I come from home in the day, I
come down in the morning, then I
smoke the first cigarette, then I
take the second cigarette, one cigarette is not enough, I
smoke the whole second cigarette continuously,
after coming, I smoke it.  In the company of two
[music] it
happened like this, I ask for 12 hours of sleep,
after that I can stay awake for any number of days, I can stay awake at
night [
music]
Wandering at
night, falling in the garden, having
fun with Lucky, having fights
and in school  After beating the students, I
sent my boys to my friends and
asked them to snatch the money [
Music] [
Music]
Bhaiya
[Music] Do the
fight at the same
time, don't forget, don't
ignore me.  But let's start
cheating, have fun Ajay Ajay Kar Na Na Na Na [
Music] Come let's go to the
garden, I do
n't have it, I don't have it, I don't have it, I don't have it [Music] Let's go
here [Music]
Idhar [
Music] So
everyone stays here only  First we have to go here, then there on the
first day, we used to go to each
station one by one, then hang in the train for a day, we did
not learn from anyone, we used to stand
slowly outside, then when the moment came, we went straight
inside
[music] just
like this, someone taught us.  There is nothing, everything is our
own
[music] by
doing [
music]
bhi pala khu wata shik galo molo bhi th kam kami kami ho gali aata tri thodi bhi wat
mana vichar
pat
ka train me
p nisha uttar hatavar gaya aap pa pa pa take  Grown
up for
a month in a empty moment, a full
month in a rickshaw, a full month without rest, having fun [
praise] [
laughter]
[music]
We both used to live together, whenever it was our
day, we lived
childhood together.  From now till now we are together
[music]
This is not us, I do not call him that
he is my friend, I treat him like my brother, I
call him you are my
friend, let's
fight, fight, anything, all together.  Mein chal
s
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
Aur [
Public aata kiti maarat aste
train me aata aap st maarte aap bhi bhatat
nahin pa public aste basleli te lokana khu wat lo ko
maraj tumhaara bate swatla ghabar nartar te
complete
Maar
ph ase marta maage pubat to
mela ma ek monday night laam maage
police
lage
police la do marle bamane marlet t
aaj pbat pkal mar
mar
ma a case has been filed against everyone else I can
never trust you
Kaap
[Music]
Li  Sam
Pas
[Music]
Although I did a lot of useless hobbies, I enjoyed
a lot,
that is, I roamed around with girls a lot and I
smoked 20 cigarettes a day. A
50 year old man will keep doing
hobbies. I have fulfilled my money-related hobbies a lot,
after this I  I have thought in life
that if there is no navy job to become something good,
then life is still there to play and jump,
no one can do anything to myself in such a hurry that
now I have to become this, I have to become that, now there is
meaning in dreaming also.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]